[Musique]
et
moi mon nom c'est à mézos locaux et à
mitch bastia et les bénévoles de
l'association hibiscus depuis 1993
depuis la création de cette association
a été créée par un groupe de jeunes du
quartier mais à une peau du bon ce temps
là c'était plutôt plus de coûter et
sportif les sportifs et culturels
les jeunes ruthénois est un petit peu
sembler fait donc la foule avait l'idée
quand même de monter entre clubs de
football doit pas super au championnat
net à quartier voilà quatre masters
avant elle était certes altéré temps
qu'à cannes saint benoît a constaté que
les normes des bâtiments que l'antenne
de construire mais ne propose pas propre
à soi rien pour les jeunes dont 97
c'est là c'est le mouvement ou la chance
je ne sais que tous n'ont n'a plus
rencontré un petit peu tous les habits
d'époque
nous avons retravaillé élaborer des
projets au fur et à mesure les oiseaux
ont évolué mais le travail était sérieux
et aujourd'hui nous travaillons avec
plusieurs partenaires
nous travaillons à mettre le saint
pierre nous travaillons le département
travaillons notre conseil régional nous
travaillons avec la caf et mathieu avait
été toujours le bénévole dans le monde
hors circuit et en 2014 mais avait passé
précisé dans ce circuit plus jeunes en
plus quand même avoir un diplôme
pendant ses comptes à travail mais la
plus chère encore plus quand même
intégré dans des entreprises c'est un
événement plus comme créer leur propre
entreprise pour nous nous trouve quand
même qu'on a fait un beau travail parce
que c'est quand même un pascal
[Musique]
vous le pré l'humain bien les oled à -
et aujourd'hui mais c'est vieux comme
higuain apparent tout mais quand même ce
que si on a la possibilité de le faire
même effet parce que cette date ne sais
tu ce dernier était là pour toujours à
venger nos sociétés je suis là une
réforme la réforme de la formation
professionnelle
quand je dis de sa peau ne financent
plus des grandes formations en terme de
préparation des tips aujourd'hui l'état
reprend petit peu en main à refinancer
des formations diplômantes les personnes
qui sont toujours dans 97 des objectifs
d'associations pourrait quand même
prouvé du terrain profitable à ce seul
gros regret aujourd'hui noir